before we get into it bro manga artist
Cuusoo mati has created an exclusive new
shirt design for our online store demon
king meliodas all hail the king if you
want to get this shirt that you can't
get anywhere else or maybe this s Canora
praise the sun or malleolus feel the
wrath click the link in the description
and check them out by buying a shirt you
are directly supporting more content
here on the channel
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about what appears to be
the end of the epic showdown between the
demon king and meliodas and the seven
deadly sins featuring of course Hawke
and Elizabeth but also Zell drous and
kinda Miele and Ludo Chell judging by
what we've just seen in Chapter three or
five of the seven deadly sins manga it
appears as if the story might be almost
over or the manga Kanaka bouzouki might
be leading us towards that conclusion
before throwing in yet another twist
massive twists have basically become the
new normal in these last few arcs of the
manga and the mangaka has kind of
trolled us in the past with the titles
and captions on the chapters so there is
a lot about this latest chapter and the
story so far that we have to unpack and
I will be doing exactly that in this
video if you enjoyed the seven deadly
sins content on this channel you want to
see more you can leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to stay up
to date on all the latest news about the
seven deadly sins such as when will the
chapters actually be ending and when
will the new anime season be announced
be sure to follow us on Twitter and
Instagram
at anime uproar as soon as we have any
reliable news we will definitely post it
there as you might expect we are talking
about the latest chapters of the seven
deadly sins manga so this video will
contain manga spoilers please proceed
with caution the name of chapter 305 is
death throes and throughout the chapter
it is implied that the demon king is
indeed on his death throes even the
cover of this chapter tells us that the
final showdown between Mele Otis and the
demon king has come and it implies that
the demon king is wailing towards demise
as the chapter starts we see Vaughan
beating on the demon king in the
physical world just after the demon king
took Zell drous out of commission we
don't know at this point if zelgius is
dead but it is clear that he is severely
injured and unconscious although this is
definitely not the first time that we've
seen Zell just in this state in the last
few arcs Vaughan unleashes on the demon
king demanding to know how he could do
something like that to Zell dress his
own flesh and blood the demon king
responds by saying i am the demon king i
have no need for weaklings in my
bloodline
if you would like to know more about the
demon king psychology and why he
considers meliodas and zelgius to be
weaklings check out my video called
inside the mind of the demon king I will
link it in the description and at the
end of this video inside the mind of the
demon king takes a deep dive into the
psyche of the demon king looking at what
makes him tick and why he does all the
terrible things that he has done
including to his own sons I hope to make
this a series in which I explore the
psychology of other fascinating anime
characters if that is something that you
were interested in definitely check out
that video and show it some love
and so while vaughn is fighting the
demon king on the outside inside of his
body meliodas uses his new technique
which he calls Trillian dark in an
attempt to get rid of every single trace
of the demon king from inside his body
melioidosis attack appears to be working
but before he is completely banished
formerly Otis's body the demon king
begins to zip around like a madman in
the physical world crashing into
everything with immense speed and force
at this point there is a brief but very
interesting exchange between hawk and
elizabeth Hawk asks if they were able to
meet meliodas and whether he was doing
okay
and Elizabeth answers yes but then she
asks why Hawk didn't come with them puck
begins to answer by saying well because
but he doesn't finish as the sins are
forced to interfere in order to stop the
demon king inside malleolus from zipping
out of control I am assuming that what
is going on at this point is that the
demon king is trying to damage when the
Otis's physical body as much as possible
before he is forced out bond forces the
demon king inside Milian's his body to
come to a stop and Elizabeth Merlin and
King together use a combo technique
called triple prison in order to keep
the demon king in one place
however the demon king breaks out and
his eyes are flashing like lightning and
other crazy stuff is happening as he
stands and faces bond when reading the
chapter for the first time I thought
that at this point the demon king
actually announces his final ultimate
technique meet darkness but then I
realized that Hawk actually jumped on
top of the demon king covered the demon
Kings eyes with his hoofs and performed
his final ultimate technique which is
apparently called meat darkness dn uses
hawks distraction to create a diamond
Tower which raises the demon king atop a
giant pillar it's good to see Deann
finally doing something again by the way
and then
moves in and 1,000,000% detroit smashes
the demon king telling him that it's
time for the real meliodas to get his
ass back here and this appears to
actually work as we see meliodas return
to his normal childlike form once again
his body is badly damaged as if he had
been beat to hell and back but all
evidence points to the battle finally
being over meliodas bond elizabeth and
the other sins all look relieved and the
captions proclaim the victory they've
been waiting for the reunion they've
been longing for at this moment the holy
war has ended the text on the side of
the page also says the demon king has
been felled and melly otis has at last
returned to the real world but is it
really all over even if meliodas and the
sins managed to force the demon king
outside Amelio's his body shouldn't the
demon king still have his original body
back in purgatory are they just going to
let the demon king be and allow him to
continue reigning as the ruler of the
demon clan and what about the supreme
deity is she going to just stay inside
the celestial realm without even making
an appearance after she was the one who
cursed Elizabeth in the first place and
speaking of the curse does Mellie Otis
now have the power to remove the curse
on his own or did the battle with the
demon king leave him too weak to do it
finally what is going on with Hawke we
don't see him after the demon king is
defeated so what in the world happened
what kind of special technique did he
suddenly use out of nowhere a technique
that allowed him to surprise the demon
king himself and distract him for long
enough for Deanna and bond to deal the
finishing blow and why wasn't Hawke able
to enter meliodas mind along with
Elizabeth and the others I am assuming
that this is directly related to the
fact that Hawk is a creature from
purgatory and that he was sent directly
by the demon king to spy on Mellie Otis
but I have no idea how exactly the two
relate to one another if you have any
ideas or theories for what happened with
hawk let me know down in the comments so
is it possible that this is really it
the battle is over and everything is
back to normal again I mean it is
possible but personally I definitely
hope that the story will continue
because there are still so many
unanswered questions questions about
hawk and the mother of chaos questions
about the supreme deity questions about
Merlin and the original Golder and
don't even get me started on the fact
that we still haven't seen mile using
his the one form man I really want to
see that one thing I do have to address
however is that after this chapter came
out I saw a decent number of people
commenting on my inside the mind of the
demon king video that the demon king
ended up being a weak character overall
I have to say that I considered this to
be completely inaccurate the demon king
wasn't even inside his own body the
commandments are present only a fraction
of his power and it took not only Mellie
Otis but the new-and-improved bond the
sins
zel dress and even hawk all working
together at the same time just to get
him out of Mellie Otis's body it is true
that Mellie Otis's original power
awakening has made malleolus extremely
opie although using his power appears to
have severe consequences including not
being able to stay in the mortal plane
for more than one day and I have no idea
what is going to happen with that by the
way so we're gonna have to wait and see
and of course this is a shown in series
and the main character is going to
become Opie at the end that's just how
it goes and we all know that a shown in
series isn't going to have a villain
like the demon king just win and kill
all the heroes the only real question is
how will the heroes get the better of
the villain and this can be done well or
it can be done poorly assuming that this
was the final battle which may not be
the case the way that the battle was
handled was really good in my opinion
Mele Otis didn't just defeat the demon
king by himself in fact despite the fact
that the demon king was fighting bond on
the outside and melioidosis emotions on
the inside at the same time at one point
it looked like miley Otis was done for
and the demon king stood over him
triumphantly it was only after the sins
entered Mele Otis's mind in order to
give him spiritual support and after
zelgius also intervened and risked his
own life and after meliodas bond the
endotherm earl in elizabeth king and
even hawk all worked together as a team
that the demon king was finally defeated
allegedly so if this was the final
showdown i think that it was definitely
epic and the demon king was most
certainly a worthy foe the battle could
have dragged on for much longer if this
had been another series another seven
deadly sins but in the end these last
few arcs were incredibly exciting
insanely fast paced and the fights were
action-packed and satisfying at least
that's my opinion but feel free to give
me your thoughts down below did you
think that the demon king was a worthy
foe and what are your thoughts on these
last
you arks overall I will be back next
week and the following weeks talking
about every chapter as long as the
chapters keep going and if you want to
discuss the chapters live with me and
ask questions be sure to follow anime
upper on Twitch link in the description
we host a 7 Deadly Sins live discussion
and QA every week after the new chapter
comes out so every Wednesday at 5 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time and everyone is
most welcome to join us if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more you
can leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell don't forget to follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at anime outpour
for all the latest updates as soon as we
have some news about when the series
will really end or when the next season
of the anime will be released we will
let you know if you feel that videos
like this one provide value for you and
you want to support more you can check
out our patreon we recently revamped the
whole thing a big thank you to all of
the patrons supporting us right now
including our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh and Keylong and
also are the one to your patrons the
ones who stand above all clans including
a17 FF DP lil lady KD and Maddie Mac 239
even donating a single dollar will give
you access to our special patron only
discord and you will see your name
appear in our videos so please if you're
interested check us out
linked in the description as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]